How accurately can we predict
the climate consequences
of carbon emissions?
How big is the uncertainty?
There is no simple
answer, but the uncertainty
varies greatly over the four
steps in the carbon climate chain.
Current emissions are known
with less than 15% error.
The uncertainty in future
emissions is immense,
as it depends on assumptions
about what the world will
look like a century from now.
How many people?
How rich?
How will they get their energy?
How much will they
care about environment?
A casual look at a 19th century
forecast of the present day
reveals the deep, enormous
uncertainty in any attempt
to predict the far future.
But the real question is not to
passively predict the future--
who's the client for that?-- but rather
to ask what kind of future we want
and aim there, understanding
the implications of our choices
for our children's future and
understanding that our children may
well have very different ideas about
the future they want than we do.
Atmospheric concentrations are
known with very high accuracy.
The concentration of
CO2 in the atmosphere
is known to much better than 1%.
Scientists understand the
carbon budget in great detail,
fitting together different
pieces of science
to tell a coherent, well-understood
story about where carbon comes from
and where it goes.
So the overall uncertainty in
predicting CO2 concentrations in, say,
the year 2100, is small, about 30%
if we knew the emissions perfectly.
It's much harder to predict
the amount of climate change
for a given increase in
carbon dioxide concentration.
Here the overall uncertainty is
perhaps a factor of two or even three.
That is, if CO2
concentrations are doubled,
temperatures might rise anywhere from
one degree, a quite small climate
change, to six degrees, a
really monstrous climate change,
though there is better than
2/3 chance that the temperature
rise would be something between one
and 1/2 and four and 1/2 degrees
centigrade.
Finally, it's harder still to predict
many of the impacts of climate change
on humans or the natural world.
Predicting the impact of climate
change on regional productivity
of crops like rice or
wheat is uncertain enough
if we had to assume that agriculture
and technology practice stays constant.
But that's the one thing we can be sure
it will not do over the next century.
Farmers will change crop
varieties and practices
to adapt to a changing climate.
So the uncertainty is
big for all the steps.
And worse still, the uncertainty
cascades from step to step.
So can we say anything useful about
the impacts of climate change in 2100?
The answer is yes.
This roulette wheel illustrates how
the future temperatures might look
if we do nothing to restrain emissions.
We could get lucky and have very
modest climate change in which
many people might even benefit.
Or with equally small odds, we might
get unlucky and have very rapid climate
change that was bad almost everywhere.
More likely the answer would
be somewhere in the middle.
Now this second wheel shows the
results of a specific climate policy.
The climate changes are much smaller.
The probability has shifted
to a much better outcome.
There is little doubt about
which world we'd rather live in.
We'd like to have less chance
of damaging climate change.
But of course, that
leaves out the question
of what it costs to cut
emissions and who pays.
Some people argue that we should ignore
climate change because our models are
poor and the uncertainty is huge.
The uncertainty is huge, but that's
not a convincing argument for inaction.
Uncertainty cuts both ways.
Reality could be better or
worse than our best guess.
It's bad policy to simply ignore
the massive changes implied
in the low probability, high impact
segment of the roulette wheel.
The hard question is not, should we do
anything, but rather how much should
we do?
Who pays?
How do we coordinate our actions around
the world to achieve a shared goal?
This question has no
single objective answer.
Values and beliefs
enter in a central way.
In forming your own
answer to that question,
you have to figure out your
own view on the basic question,
how much does climate change matter?
How might it affect our lives or the
lives of our great grandchildren?
And how does it compare to the many
other challenges humanity faces?
Not all climate changes
will be bad for all people.
People in northern latitudes
may benefit as a growing
seasons lengthen for important crops.
Industries that want to
exploit resources in the Arctic
may benefit from the nearly ice-free
conditions in the summertime.
But there is little doubt that
most people in the natural world
will be worse off if
climate changes fast.
And it's a certainty that
if humans in this century
let CO2 concentrations get to, say,
three times their pre-industrial value,
they will deprive future
generations of a chance
to enjoy much of the natural world as
it was at the start of the Industrial
Revolution.